It has been dubbed hell on earth
for those incarcerated here.
Like when you are like dead, you
cannot eat. You cannot drink.
A place commonly known for its
ubiquitous torture practices.
Indefinite detention without charges
and trial is a human rights violation.
Lack of medical care is a human rights violation.
Guantanamo is turning 20 years old - 39 out of
almost 800 prisoners have been kept there through
today. Some of them without criminal charges.
We’re ashamed that everything that
made this country one that we could
say that was a free country, that had equal
justice for all, has abandoned all of that.
We are here at the infamous Guantanamo
Bay detention facility in Cuba and I'll
be taking you with me to look at the world’s
most notorious prison. Guantanamo first opened
20 years ago and some of its remaining inmates
have been waiting for their trials ever since,
often in inhumane conditions. In this video, I'll
take you through why Guantanamo still exists, and
examine whether it can ever really be shut down.
But first let’s look at how everything began.
On September 11, 2001 the United States was hit
by unparalleled terror attacks carried out by
al-Qaida. Thousands of people died. The United
States and its allies were shaken to the core.
The US government was looking for an
answer that was equally forceful and clear.
Make no mistake: The United States
will hunt down and punish those
responsible, for these cowardly acts.
The answer came soon: The United States and its
allies launched a global war on terror. More and
more suspects were captured – and later sent
to the US navy base at Guantanamo Bay in Cuba.
A place outside the public eye. Far from
American soil. Where the US constitution
does not exist and nobody is watching.
Very soon, Guantanamo hit the headlines:
reports of torture came to light. And that led
to some fundamental, and unsettling, questions:
Was America, a longtime fighter for human
rights, hiding its terror suspects in a
detention facility, tucked away on a small bit
of land in Cuba, so that nobody could see what
was really happening here, behind barbed wire
fences? Was America losing its moral authority?
The base is only accessible by plane from the
United States. Only the US military can allow
visitors to the base. We have to play by their
rules. And that means: filming is very limited.
Guantanamo consists of a
navy base, a military court,
and the infamous prison – that part, however,
is off limits for our camera – for good reason.
Can you summarize from the perspective
of Amnesty International, what
are the human rights violations
that are taking place in Guantanamo?
Indefinite detention without charges
and trial is a human rights violation.
Lack of medical care is a human rights violation.
Lack of treatment for torture is a
human rights violation.
Lack of accountability
for torture is a human rights violation.
There are so many human rights violations
involved in Guantanamo. That’s why we’ve opposed
it for so many years and that’s why we think the
Biden administration really needs to take
every measure it can to shut it down now.
The biggest obstacle for us is that everything
you see in this video has been recorded under
surveillance by the US Army. It has
gone through extensive censorship. Or
it is archive footage that was given to us
and therefore shows a sugarcoated version
of Guantanamo. No picture or video may leave
the base without the Army’s approval. Plus
we didn’t get any access to the detention
facilities, so it’s hard to find out what’s
really going on behind these walls. But one man
who has spent years as an inmate can tell us more.
Mohamedou Ould Slahi, a former resident of
Germany, was held in Guantanamo for 14 years. He
was suspected as being the head recruiter for the
9/11 attacks but was never charged with a crime.
His book “Guantanamo Diaries” – now hitting the
big screen as “The Mauritanian” - shows in great
detail how he was brutally tortured. He suffers
from post-traumatic stress disorder to this day.
Like when you are like dead, you cannot eat.
You cannot drink. You cannot do anything and
you cannot sleep most more. You cannot
sleep. And you just like waiting to die.
No, this is like the worst manifestation I had.
I wake up sometimes just like three or four nights
ago, I woke up and I was shaking so scared because
I saw my jacket on the door and I thought it was
someone coming to get me. And it took me a very
long time. Sometimes I wake up, I cannot breathe,
you know, but I'm facing this, you know, because
like, getting your ducks in a row is a myth.
Nancy Hollander defended Mohamedou at court.
Well, Mohammed was tortured more
severely than anyone else in Guantanamo,
with the possible exception of a prisoner named
Katana, who is still there. (…) But you know,
if you see the movie (…) you'll find
out that what the movie says and shows
is what happened to him. (…) You know, the movie
can't show 70 days of not being given more than an
hour to sleep, night on, some nights no sleep,
so that he basically began to hallucinate.
At the heart of Guantanamo is the military
court – the so called Camp Justice.
The majority of the remaining inmates are
still waiting for their trials - some of them
20 years after being brought here. Among
them are the alleged masterminds of 9/11
like Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and Ramzi Binalshib.
Some 13 detainees are cleared to be released,
but are still being kept in Guantanamo
– without any charges at all.
We cannot film at court. But we can talk to
defense attorney Anthony Natale. His client
is the alleged al-Qaida terrorist
Al-Nashiri who arrived here in 2006
and has been waiting for his trial ever since.
Guantanamo has been seen internationally as
a stain on American history. So where
does this place put the United States?
We’re ashamed that everything
that made this country
one that we could say that was a free country,
that had equal justice for all, has abandoned
all of that. And that’s sad and I don’t
know how we’re going to be able to recover.
It has become a rallying point to recruit
other extremists. It has been something that
has been thrown in the face of Americans
and the US government whenever we want to
criticize human rights anywhere else. I don’t
see it. To be quite frank: if there was a reason,
they’re not telling us and they’re
not telling the public of the world,
why do they have to continue this.
In the shadow of the detention camp
lies another side of Guantanamo. The US Naval
Base has been there for almost 120 years.
Residential areas resemble small-town America.
This is where soldiers and their families live.
Cuba’s only McDonald’s is here.
The contrasts to the detention
camp couldn’t be clearer.
This is what the military wants us
to show: some normalcy. A Navy base,
where people go about their everyday lives. To us
it really seems like a world of double standards.
You have the notorious prison and the court
on the one hand, and the 6,000 inhabitants
of Guantanamo on the other. But the prison and
what happens there is a forbidden topic for them,
and we’re not even allowed to
talk to people on the streets.
But we are allowed to film at Radio GTMO, the
oldest radio station of the armed forces network.
The soundtrack for Guantanamo comes
from here and she is Gitmo’s voice.
Hello Gitmo, hello hello, welcome to your
morning show with DJ Candis otherwise known
as Petty Officer Annaliss Candelaria.
It’s pretty early in the morning, 8 a.m.
Court trials and the prison
are not part of their coverage.
It’s not really part of the culture here.
That’s another side of the base. Here on
this side we have a whole different type of
operations going here, because as you know
this is an important fueling station. This is
an important base for the military in general.
The new pride of the base is the school
which was just reopened in a new building.
This elementary school classroom comes with
state-of-the-art technology and allows its
students somewhat of a normal childhood. Five
kilometers from the notorious detention facility.
But prison and court are not on the curriculum.
We focus on the idea of curriculum standards,
our mission is to provide the best education
that out students should get.
For several US presidents the detention camp was
a thorny topic on their agenda. President Obama
was the first who wanted to close Guantanamo.
I don’t want to pass this problem on to
the next president no matter who it is.
Are we going to let this linger on for
another 15 years? For another 20 years?
Obama failed - President Trump changed course.
To re-examine our military detention policy.
And to keep open the detention
facilities at Guantanamo bay.
And the Biden administration
has again shifted back.
Yes our goal is to close Guantanamo. I don’t
have a timeline for you but there’s a process,
there are different layers of the process.
But how long that will take is incredibly unclear.
Ultimately, the detention center was built
to detain terrorists and war criminals
and have them face trial in a military court.
Out of 800 detainees that were held in Gitmo,
only eight have been convicted and four
of these convictions have been overturned.
That leaves us with the question: what is taking
so long? And can there ever be an end to this?
Well, there is a law on the books
in the United States that says
no one who has ever been in Guantanamo can come
to the US for any purpose, trial, medical etc.
But moving them, just making a Guantanamo North is
not the answer to this question. These people need
to be released. We can't hold people for 20 years
without any charge because, according to the US,
there's not enough evidence to charge them,
but we somehow know they're dangerous.
Cliff Sloan was President Obama’s envoy
for closing Guantanamo. He believes the
Biden administration is running out of time.
There are many things that could be done and
that need to be done by President Biden and
the administration, and I don't doubt their
commitment and their good faith. But the pact
needs to be picked up to know. The 27 who are not
charged with anything need to be transferred to
other countries right away, and especially with
13 who are approved for transfer. In the first
year of the Biden administration. We've only
seen one person transferred from Guantanamo
and that is far, far too slow of a pace.
Do you think Guantanamo will ever close down?
Yes, yes, absolutely. I think even the US
government will come to realize that having an
entire prison camp on their military base in Cuba
to hold a handful of men were right now 39. But
as that number get smaller and smaller
it will become more and more clear and
how irrational it is, how absurd it is.
Can it? Absolutely! Will it?
God only knows. But it certainly can be
closed. All the needs can be accommodated,
without having a prison that is
riddled with a history of torture.
A court system which is flawed beyond repair.
It’s a shameful anniversary.
The Anniversary Guantanamo is a stain
on the United States, but as a result.
The answer isn't. Either turn the other
way or to raise our hands in frustration.
The answer (is to?) move forward and close
it and end this long, unfortunate chapter.
As promptly as (missing text) And I hope
that this year, the 20th anniversary,
is going to be the year that we are finally,
finally, going to see Guantanamo closed.
You know, I thought at the beginning of the
Obama administration that it was going to
happen. It clearly didn't I thought at the
beginning of the Biden administration that
it was going to happen, and now I don't see how,
unless he really moves quickly and he is willing
to expend the political capital necessary to do
that. But you know it all comes down to politics.
How far is he willing to go, given the Republicans
who refused to move on any issue whatsoever?
And I just don't know. Now I'm beginning to be
more pessimistic than I was at the beginning.
The debate about the closure of the Guantanamo is
as old as the detention camp itself. Presidents
famously vowed to transfer inmates to the mainland
US – and famously failed. Twenty years after 9/11,
the detention camp at Guantanamo Bay continues
to be a stain on America's global reputation.
And several dozen detainees are
still waiting for their trials.